Continuing in Al Wajiz, the chapters
that we have finished are the chapters
of
hygiene and purification. Now, the
author takes us into
something that is closely related to
both, and oftentimes it is
mentioned in this place in the books of
Hadith, most popularly,
due to the fact that it is closely
connected to
both of these topics.
And that is
the topic of Adab al-Khala.
The etiquettes of relieving oneself, and
the etiquettes
of
using what we would refer to as the
restroom, or using what we would refer
to as the place
of relieving oneself.
[Silence]
So,
first, the author tells us that it is
preferred
that for an individual who wishes to
relieve himself,
that when they enter the area that they
are going to the general area that
they're going to relieve themself in,
they say bi
bismillah
that they say bismillah,
"Oh Allah,
I seek refuge in you from
evil and its souls."
[Arabic recitation]
narrations.
The first narration is the narration
of Ali ibn Abi Talib
in which
the author will mention.
And the second is the narration of Anas.
Because when a person is going to enter
into an area where he's going to relieve
himself,
there's two things that have to happen
here.
Number one, the person has to eventually
expose his private parts or hers.
And second,
the person is going to go into that very
vulnerable act of relieving oneself.
The human being is
prime
real estate.
The human being is the
subject of
the wars that take place
in the heavens and on earth. All this
for the soul and the heart of the human
being.
So, the human being
is surrounded constantly by enemies,
enemies of humankind, enemies of
jinnkind.
Now, the enemies of jinnkind, we do not
see them. We cannot see them. We cannot
hear them.
We cannot speak to them, but they can
see us, and they can hear us. And this
places us at a disadvantage.
And so, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
levels that playing field by
promising that if we seek refuge in him,
subhanahu wa ta'ala, he will grant us
a
momentary
refuge.
Momentary
refuge. Is the person ever going to be
done
with the shaytan?
Not as long as a person's on this earth.
Every human being, even the prophets and
messengers,
except for Maryam
and Isa alayhima as-salam.
They are the only two that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala had completely
and entirely protected from a shaytan to
the point where they were not even
interfered with by a shaytan, and this
is one of the miracles that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala gave to Isa
alayhissalam.
Otherwise, the sworn enemy of the human
being is a shaytan. A shaytan A shaytan
here meaning Iblis, and a shaytan
meaning the devils, the devil kind.
Right?
And so, a person is only given momentary
reprieve from a shaytan.
Well, when a person says, "A'udhu
billahi min ash-shaytan ir-rajeem." It
is momentary.
It is limited. It's not forever.
That is your enemy. That is the
that is the
one that you are to strive and
struggle against and in that struggle
you will find your own definition. And
so
these two things that are taking place.
A person is exposing himself. Second of
all, a person is in a vulnerable state
of relieving himself and relieving
himself
and not able to remember Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala during this very vulnerable
time.
And so
first we have the narration of Ali ibn
Abi Talib, which is in
As-Sunan
in which the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam says
satru ma bayna a'yunil jinn
[Arabic recitation]
bani Adam idha dakhala ahaduhumul
khala'a an yaqula bismillah.
The
barrier, the veil
between the private parts of the human
being and
the eyes of the jinn is that the
person say bismillah.
So when a person says bismillah, this
conceals his or her private parts.
Now
notice here how these are two different
narrations. This narration isn't
specific for relieving oneself.
This is for any time a person is to
expose his or her private parts. Any
time a person is to expose his or her
private parts, they say what? Bismillah.
They say bismillah.
The next is the narration of Anas
who narrates that the messenger of Allah
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Anas narrates that the messenger of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala when he would
go to relieve himself, he would say, "Oh
Allah, I seek refuge in you from
the
from evil and its souls
or I seek refuge in you from
the male and female devils."
[Silence]
And notice here how the author says
"Idha dakhala al-khala'." What is
al-khala'? alaihi wasallam in his time
well, not just his time, but his region.
Did they have
bathrooms? Did they have outhouses?
Did they have like
a little restroom where a person would
go and open the door and go inside and
close the door behind them and there's
a sink there where he could wash
his hands and then a place to use
the bathroom and you know, maybe there's
a bidet there or maybe there's a shower
sitting right there. No, this is not
what
al al al khala looked like. Al khala
was
an area designated by the townsfolk that
they would all go to use to relieve
themselves
or if you're traveling, any opportune
area where a person could achieve some
kind of privacy when they would wish to
relieve himself.
This is what al khala is and al khala
men al khulu.
Al khala is taken from the root word al
khulu which is for a place to be empty.
So, it's referred to as al khala
meaning the person is going to the place
that is empty
that is private.
Why are they going to the private place
to do private things, right? To relieve
oneself.
And so,
there's no door or threshold that
here I'm outside of the bathroom and
here I've crossed over into the
bathroom. No.
It's whenever he would
go to the place where he's chosen, this
is the place
where I'm going to relieve myself
and then
just as a person would go to it's open
to the outdoors, right? And then just as
the person would go to
uncover his hour they say bismillah and
just as they
go to sit or assume a position of of
you know, relieving oneself they say
[Arabic recitation]
al-khubthi wal-khaba'ith. This is when a
person would say this.
Now, why is this point important?
What we'll come to learn is that saying
bismillah for instance
before making wudu
this is
the least case
the sunnah
and the most case it is a condition of a
person's wudu being valid.
So, many scholars have viewed it as
being obligatory.
Now, a lot of times
in our culture and our modern
world that we live in
the bathroom
and the restroom are one.
When I say the bathroom, the place where
the bath takes place, place where the
water is.
Bathroom in Arabic is al-hammam.
Okay?
Meaning al-hamim, makan al-hamim, al-ma'
al-har.
And the restroom, which is al-khala.
And so, these are in the same place. If
you want to wash your hands, you got to
go to the same place that you relieve
yourself. If you want to relieve
yourself, you got to go to the same
place where you would, make wudu
oftentimes.
Right?
And so,
if a person what are the parameters of
the area where you are not to say
bismillah at?
Right?
Is that right next to the toilets? Is
that the entire place region that is
called the bathroom?
No.
It is right at the toilet. That is where
it is
considered to be
makruh. At at most, it is
strongly dispraised
that a person mention Allah's name.
But when a person is
by the sinks,
you know, let's say a public
bathroom,
there are stalls. Those stalls that is
al-khala. That is the restroom,
shara'an.
And the sinks, this is the place where
people come to wash up.
This is not the place where
a person is to not say Allah's name.
Right?
Those are the parameters.
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
And finally, when a person
is concluded, finished, and they leave
the area of al-khala,
it is
preferred that a person say
ghufranak.
[Arabic recitation]
of
you know, what we would refer to as the
restroom, they would say, "Ghufranak."
Which
directly translates to, "Oh Allah, I
seek from you your pardon and
forgiveness."
And this is due to the narration of
Aisha
in which she narrates that the Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam, when he
would conclude and leave the area of
relieving himself, he would say,
"Ghufranak." It's just one word,
"Ghufranak."
Now,
there are other narrations
for entering the restroom. All of them
are weak outside of the two that we
mentioned. The narration of Anas and the
[Arabic recitation]
inni audhubika min al-khubthi
wal-khabaith. No other narration is
authentic in that regard. And there are
other narrations for
dua to be made once a person leaves
the
restroom area.
And that is
"Ghufranak."
And that is the only authentic narration
in that regard. All other narrations in
that regard, in that meaning,
are
inauthentic, such as "Ghufranak,
[Arabic recitation]
alhamdulillah alladhi adhhaba anni
al-
al-adha
[Arabic recitation]
adhhaba anni al-
Alhamdulillah led the alpha near
men
Jack the real yacht
and the Nabi Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
What can he mean I used to tell the wife
of her?
the wife of her When he has a shower and
he Sallallahu alaihi wasallam call
you Goff run it. Kelly man why he that?
And so
the only authentic the kid
when a person goes to enter the restroom
is
along with me out of the back of the
hood fee with her back it or to say I
will hold the fee with her back it. Both
have been narrated.
And the only authentic remembrance when
a person is concluded
is to say
Goff run it.
That's all Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala be
many with her with you that I live in a
mine found and in found a man I live in
a mine you see that and I am a Allah
Allah Allah Allah Allah